Where can I find the best information until you're on a machine? It might be on your site.
I could not find last week Zoom call. I looked all over.
So first of all, last week Zoom call is going to be on our video site. How do you get to the video
site? Low to the member site. On the member site, you can go to the Zoom calls. There's a link to the
to the video site from the member site. Also go to our website and you can look in the upper
corner. It will say videos that will link to our video site as well. Our video site is videos.cuttersclinic.com.
So that will that will all get you to the sites that you're looking for. So if you click on our website
and you click bot blog, you'll see books, videos, newsletters, click on videos,
and you'll see our new video site platform. And then on the video site, once you're at videos.cuttersclinic.com,
you can click on the left hand side where it shows the latest videos and those are all the latest
videos that are updated. And all the videos are separated. The Zoom calls are separated with
the smaller videos. Number two, how do I get to the best information of the Atelier Robin,
go to our website. So on our website, you're going to see videos on the right machine and the difference
between the rights on our website, also on the frequency course. So you all have access to all the
courses, the frequency course, as information on the different, the different, um, uh, right for
sheets. I also, on the video site, I go into details with some different videos on the Atelier Robin,
on the video site. I think I'm on there right now if I just search atelier. Uh, I, you'll see a
bunch of videos on Atelier Robin. One of the videos says, would you recommend the Atelier Robin
or the true right? And then other say, um, about the Atelier Robin, new programs, a whole bunch of
videos on the Atelier Robin. So that's where I would go. Otherwise, you can call the clinic and talk
to room as well.